[Music]
you are single what are you looking for
in a guy maybe i can help you what kind
of guy do you like okay the last time i
was here
it kind of spiraled out of control since
then um
it started here with a beard that you
place gently in my mouth
did i do that you don't remember i was
in a very zen place i don't remember
what i did
i had a beard i had a beard for a while
and and uh you tasted my beard yeah i um
put it in my mouth okay yeah so then i
like so then i i did i take things too
far sometimes no
[Laughter]
so you tasted my beard and that made you
and it just like then it was just like
really downhill from there because then
i started this tumblr page and i just
started putting every
rogue beard i could find just in my
mouth it really you'd meet a guy who had
a beard and you would let the guy put
the beard in your mouth i wouldn't let
him i would request it but request it
[Laughter]
come to me
so okay so you started doing that so you
like guys with beards now i always did
boo
don't you
who keeps coming in behind me in this
show who's boo
oh okay sorry
i don't know what the kids are doing
these days uh so you like beards you
like guys with beaches i've always liked
beards because i feel like sometimes
it's like
is he homeless
it's like
a really fun game
okay
have you actually gone to because there
are competitions oh yeah like where they
have guys with all kind of crazy insane
mustaches and beards that are all
twirled around have you been to any of
those oh yeah no i've i frequent and
there's one in particular it was like
it was like porn i gotta tell you
because i went there and they're all
like lined up with their beards and
they're like rated and some of them were
just like taking their clothes off it
was very erotic well that that doesn't
sound like that is porn you were
you were clearly had wandered and if
they're taking their clothes off
was heavy bass music playing at the time
so
and what kind of beards are we talking
about so okay my personal favorite was
this one beard was so magical and it was
so big and inside of his beard crevices
he had sea creatures and little baby
dinosaur figurines
if you know anything about me
i love dinosaurs
it's just
so random
so did you start dating this guy no but
i did make out with him for like two
seconds
did you get like a dinosaur in your
mouth accidentally
that's something you could be in
dangerous like my fantasy oh
okay
all right
[Applause]
we gotta take a break
[Applause]